China's version of tick tock has a very
different algorithm that doesn't allow
this kind of content it doesn't specify
stem or anything like that though think
of all the influencers that will be out
of a job if they ban it here in America
what will they do but you don't make you
don't make real money on Tick Tock you
make like they push you towards brand
deals though right they a large amount
of following gets them more content with
other types of products that they sell
through their let me put it this way you
can make money on Tick Tock you can make
money on Instagram in terms of social
media I think YouTube is the highest
um like viewed a dollar ratio yeah and
it's still crappy podcasts are the best
audio version podcasts have like the
best CPM if you want to make money on
ads and sponsorships it's audio podcasts
Instagram reels actually do fairly well
for mid-level creators and down right
probably not for the larger ones because
there's a cap on how much you can make
per per month
Facebook does way better yeah so putting
putting your videos on Facebook makes
like 10 times the money of Instagram